it has been announced yet the Prime
Minister announced it saying from
midnight tonight for the next 21 days
the country is going to be in a lockdown
but we had to bear in mind that we are a
federal state a lot of the states have
already placed the areas of their states
into a lockdown I mean early this
morning
Somalia there were about 32 states which
had already placed a lockdown in their
respective areas of control and there
were just a few who were out of who had
partial sort of lockdown but now it has
become a very formal and very
restrictive federal command from the
Prime Minister himself to lock it down
only essential services people run the
hospital police essential government
services the media and others who are in
absolute essential work be allowed to go
or to be on the road or in public spaces
apart from them no one will be allowed
to be on the road he's emphasised social
distancing is emphasized he want to save
this country he's given examples of
Italy China Italy the United States
talking about how good their medical
services are but still they have been
ravaged by this virus and we need to do
some base stringent action now and he's
asked people to stay in we we still
don't know what's the kind of what the
violations if any by anything any by
general public what is what it's going
to entail in terms of legal action but
we've already seen a lot of the states
taking very stringent action in their
areas to stop people from going out